good evening delighted to welcome you
all back to the fourth and final Terry
lecture for 2006 those of you who have
followed the lectures so far have I'm
sure but impressed by the breadth of
every Edition displayed by Professor
barber Heron Stein Smith her command of
the literature of what she labels the
new naturalism is stunning as well as
the comments of its critics but even
more impressive is the analytical care
with which she explores arguments both
scientific and theological that
sophistication presented in lucid prose
is matched by the sympathetic hearing
she is able to provide even for
physicians with which he is not in full
agreement we've now heard about attempts
to explain religion as a natural
phenomenon on the basis of evolutionary
psychology and cognitive theory we have
also heard about attempts to find a
space for a theological analysis of the
natural order compatible with
contemporary science in each case we
have heard why such efforts are not
entirely persuasive the efforts of the
new naturalism and the new natural
theology are as professor Harron Stein
Smith suggests reflections of one
another and hence her lecture today
we'll explore that reflexivity the title
reflections science and religion natural
and unnatural please welcome back to the
podium professor Barbara herons Dean
Smith
Thank You Harry I'd also like to thank
since it's my last public appearance
here the members of the Terry committee
especially Harry Attridge bill summers
Dale Martin gene black and Leo Hickey
along with YG Dimmick and frank turner
for their extraordinary hospitality
during my stay here and Barbara Mordecai
for attentions behind the scene and
lorilee field for attentions
consistently above and beyond and the
yale university community for supplying
such a wonderful audience for these
lectures one of my central points in
these lectures explicit in the first two
is that there are better and worse ways
of pursuing the naturalistic study of
religion there are also I think better
in worse ways of promoting the
specifically cognitive evolutionary
accounts of religion currently being
developed what I've been calling here
the new naturalism and unfolding their
implications intellectual institutional
and to a certain extent ideological
these different ways of reflecting on
the new naturalism and more generally on
the relation of science to religion will
be my focus in this final lecture i'll
begin by commenting on a key term that
has remained unexamined here namely
naturalism itself the current
theological wisdom sorry the current
theoretical wisdom shared by many
philosophers of science and theologians
is that naturalism comes in two forms
methodological and metaphysical
methodological naturalism often equated
with the practices of science is the
principled exclusion of appeals to
supernatural beings or forces from a
certain class of investigations and
theories that we call partly on that
account
scientific metaphysical naturalism often
equated or associated with materialism
or atheism is the view that there is no
realm of being beyond and no entities or
forces other than the material the
physical or as might be said that which
is in nature but what do we mean by any
of these terms and how can we specify
neutrally without metaphysical
assumptions and thus just going in
circles that which is to be understood
as ontologically complete that's a
lingering and difficult question in
these debates which I won't attempt to
answer here obviously there can be no
simple or single answer but I will be
poking at it from a variety of angles
the distinction between the two forms of
naturalism figures crucially in a range
of current controversies over the
relation between science and religion
for example theological critic Paul
Griffiths whom we encountered in the
first lecture predicting that the
scientific study of religion has no
future charges scholars who promote
naturalistic approaches in religious
studies with self refutation based on
the argument that since those scholars
evidently think that naturalism is true
but have no empirical grounds for
thinking so they are making metaphysical
claims just like the theologians whose
claims about religion they reject for
just that reason but one may reply
naturalism pursued as a method is not
the kind of thing that can be true or
false rather like using low octane fuel
or following a low-fat diet it can only
be more or less appropriate for the
purposes at hand and carried out more or
less effectively accordingly the pursuit
or promotion of methodological
naturalism in religious studies or
elsewhere is not open to the charge of
self refutation or as in Griffiths
argument and elsewhere to the taunt of
to quote way you too so there the
distinction also figures and replies to
proponents of intelligent design who
charge that the decision by evolutionary
biologists to leave divine purpose out
of their explanations is arbitrary or
based just on personal atheism here one
may reply that the exclusion has been
practiced as a matter of method by
theistic as well as atheistic scientists
and that it reflects not only
long-standing considerations of
theoretical and cognitive economy but
also significantly here the ongoing
observation of the practical reliability
of explanations so constructed where
divine purpose is included in an
explanation of natural phenomena the
result as I suggested in the last
lecture may be more congenial to people
with religiously instructed cognitive
tastes but the broader communal
advantages of maintaining those
exclusions notably the practical
reliability of the explanatory theories
thereby constructed are forfeited that's
why PO che its proponents intelligent
design cannot be claimed as a viable
scientific alternative to the Darwinian
theory of natural selection but two
points must be added to the current
philosophical wisdom about naturalism
one is that the distinction between its
metaphysical and methodological forms is
not always clear for example there's
some question as to whether at the
apparent limits of scientific knowledge
say in cosmology or quantum theory the
exclusion of the possibility of types of
entities or forces other than those
currently comprehended by the Natural
Sciences doesn't amount to both a
metaphysical claim
and a possibly significant intellectual
confinement or to put it another way
whether under those conditions
methodological naturalism doesn't become
in effect metaphysical naturalism to be
sure the possibility of such slippage or
indistinctness doesn't give an epistemic
boost to any specific religious or
theistic claim notions such as the
existence of a personal deity don't
become any more valid just because some
scientific ideas or programs involve
metaphysical assumptions but it does put
both the theistic affirmations and the
naturalistic rejections of so-called
spooky forces equally outside empirical
falsification under those limit
conditions they are in effect matters of
ontological taste the second point which
I suggested a moment ago is that in many
current in vacations of naturalism it's
assumed that nature itself along with
what's in it is something self-evidently
given an unproblematic but of course
that's hardly the case without
rehearsing here the long history of the
term in Western thought we may recall
first the very length of that history
our current term nature translates a
number of significantly different terms
not tour of scissors and so forth from
antiquity and second the multiplicity of
meanings that would be yielded by any
analysis of even its current usages thus
while in many scientific and
philosophical contexts and related
formal discourses nature is equivalent
to reality the cosmos or simply
everything that exists but I referred to
before as the ontological a complete we
also often distinguish it from various
other realms or forms of existence for
example from the man-made the human or
the social as in the familiar
opposition's of nature to art or culture
or from the mental as in the con
between what is actually in nature as
opposed to what is merely in our dreams
or wishes and of course we distinguish
the natural from what we call the
supernatural and vice versa indeed in
contemporary Western discourse the two
terms are mutually dependent and
reciprocally signifying that is we can
speak of the supernatural only because
we have nature and many languages and
cultures didn't and some still don't
have that contra distinction or finally
invoking nature normatively but
ambivalently as in medical moral or
aesthetic discourses we speak of the
natural positively in contrast to the
adulterated the abnormal or the perverse
but also sometimes negatively in
contrast to the refined the civilized
the developed or the extraordinary
clearly whatever else it is nature is an
ocean an idea and abstraction a human
construct we humans Westerners
scientists philosophers keep
constructing nature collectively out of
our inter subjectively communicated
interactions with publicly available
phenomena as distinct from such other
phenomena as our personal dreams or
individual visions at the same time
however each of us keeps constructing
our own individual world out of
everything we experience individually
everything including our personal dreams
and as may happen our personal
intuitions or visions of the unity or
duality or divinity of the universe
nature the real may be seen as a
collective construct and as such both
historically and culturally variable but
also shared by the members of an
epistemic community that may be quite
extensive but our personal ontologies
our universe constructs are highly
individuated and as such both unique to
each of us and also as I suggested in
the second lecture more or less scrappy
that is patchworks or assemblages of
logically contradictory ideas and images
drawn from many domains and levels of
experience for most of us I think
including most scientists and endorses
of methodological naturalism there is as
Hamlet says to Horatio more in heaven
and hell then dreamt of in your or our
philosophy or as I would gloss that for
our present purposes more in our
individual encounters with the universe
than is set forth in current scientific
accounts of the shared physical
phenomenal world some people however
aspire to be full-time metaphysical
naturalist's and do not permit anything
to enter their individual ontologies or
acknowledge that there is anything in
them except with that I what they have
put there on good scientific Authority
these include what I call the
evangelical skeptics metaphysical
naturalist's convinced that the way they
conduct their own cognitive lives is the
way everyone universally should conduct
his or hers as it happens a number of
such evangelicals including some
well-known evolutionary theorists have
involved themselves in current debates
over the nature value and future of
respectively and contrastive lee science
and religion which brings me to the main
topic of today's lecture
as we've seen what solves the
evolutionary riddle of religion in the
new naturalist accounts of it that is
what explains the persistence of
religious beliefs and practices in spite
of their evident costs in biological
Fitness is that they are the products or
byproducts of cognitive mechanisms
impulses intuitions systems of responses
and so forth that conferred fitness
benefits on our Stone Age ancestors thus
evolutionary psychologists Pascal Boyer
in a passage of particular interest here
today observes that religion is a likely
thing because as he puts it supernatural
concepts are parasitic on mental systems
that would be there in any case indeed
Boyer adds invoking a currently
circulating conceit that is kind of
artful idea he adds religion is a much
more likely thing than science because
religion is natural while science is
unnatural Boyer sites as supporting this
claim a recent essay by rob mccolley
whom we encountered in the first lecture
is co-author of the self-consciously
confrontational new naturalist book
rethinking religion the essay in
question is titled the naturalness of
religion and the unnaturalness of
science in which Macaulay echoes the
arguments of a book by British biologist
Lewis Wolpert its self-titled the
unnatural nature of science these shared
claims and duplicated arguments are
worth our attention here McCauley
explains that his essay is provoked by
scholars who maintain that because
religion is not or not simply a natural
phenomenon its study requires methods
other than those of the natural sciences
seeking to turn the tables on such
arguments Macaulay replies that religion
is on
contrary something supremely natural
while it is actually science that is
unnatural as is often the case however
with polemical table turnings the
reversal here does not come off all
together smoothly the argument as
Macaulay lays it out consists of a
series of strongly contrastive
characterizations appealing to
apparently straightforward observations
supplemented by historical and
experimental evidence thus he argues
that we may conclude from the fact that
religion is found in all times and
cultures that it requires nothing but
the universals of human nature to spring
up while conversely given the historical
and cultural rarity of science we may
conclude that it is essentially contrary
to human nature or later that in as much
as science requires literacy complex
social arrangements educated elites and
technical means for preserving and
transmitting knowledge it is
fundamentally cultural while conversely
in as much as religion requires nothing
but basic cognitive abilities it is non
cultural or again that from the fact
that religious concepts are easy to
learn and remember and quickly acquired
even by young children we may conclude
that they conform to innate intuitions
whereas from the fact that scientific
concepts are hard to learn and take
specialists years of hard study to
master we may conclude that they are
counterintuitive and demand exceptional
forms of cognitive discipline these
contrasts are in some ways plausible
sounding draw on familiar observations
and are presented by Macaulay with a
string of references to the
psychological literature but the
distinctions and alignments on which
they're based involve considerable
conceptual oversimplification and
historical obliteration
for one thing it's not clear in many of
these observations that comparable
matters are being compared thus at the
simplest level we may ask what exactly
is it in religion that children acquire
so easily and in science that most
people never come to master to be sure
many children who can recite their
prayers with ease would have difficulty
explaining Einstein's unified field
theory but many children who can recite
the multiplication table at the drop of
a hat would have difficulty explaining
the doctrine of the Trinity what appears
to be the case but is quite distorted
here in the service of a strained
contrast is that certain concepts and
verbal routines whether religious
scientific philosophical or mathematical
are acquired readily while other more
complex or sophisticated concepts and
formulations again from various domains
require a highly specialized education
and long apprenticeship for their
mastery second and more fundamentally in
McCauley's essay as in wolpert's book
and other current in vacations of the
natural supernatural opposition the
contrast between science and religion
requires representing each as a monolith
and defining both in tendentious
artificially broad artificially narrow
or otherwise strained ways for example
while Macaulay obviously includes in
religion everything from Neanderthal
burial practices one of his examples to
Vatican encyclicals he insists on a
quite narrow historically and culturally
specific understanding of science which
of course begs the question of the
latter's alleged historical and cultural
rarity the sharp distinction and strong
contrast between science and religion
here also require are forgetting quite a
bit of recorded human history as opposed
to tales of prehistoric life for example
the extensive historical continuities
between the
too including for the better part of the
past millennium in the close
intellectual as well as institutional
ties between Western science and
Christian theology historians of the
subject remind us that much of science
originally pursued as natural philosophy
developed in medieval universities that
were originally based in monastic orders
and that such pursuits remained
theologically oriented long afterward as
late as the 18th century nature was
studied systematically by among others
Isaac Newton on the assumption that an
embodied divine purpose and what the aim
of revealing just how it did so indeed a
number of familiar ideals in science
such as the unity progress and
perfectibility of knowledge of the
fairly direct heritage of christian
doctrine transmitted through the
medieval universities and extended by
enlightenment and evolutionary
narratives of human rationality and
development these and other norms and
notions shared by Western science and
Western religion may also reflect more
general human cognitive tendencies for
example those that incline people
everywhere to construct teleological and
mill Urist narratives stories of onward
and upward and those that seem to
incline men generally to the sense that
a strong testosterone Express is
required for important works of the mind
or the spirit Macaulay acknowledges at
one point that scientists exhibit the
same biases and the same cognitive
biases and limitations that other human
beings do but he continues scientists
get around such biases and limitations
through tools quote tools such as
literacy and mathematical description
and through certain norms established in
pained by the institution of science
norms he writes following here
traditional sociology of science which
encouraged scientists to quote seize
opportunities to criticize and correct
each other's work the techniques and
norms that Macaulay invokes here are
certainly significant in sustaining the
authority and reliability of scientific
knowledge but their operation is not as
simple or their effectiveness as
decisive as he implies among other more
general cognitive tendencies that
scientists share with non scientists
including poets visionaries and
religious communicants are animism
anthropomorphism overgeneralization
reification hypertrophy binary thinking
hierarchical thinking linear causal
thinking and teleological thinking as
we've seen a number of these shared
tendencies are illustrated in the
conduct of the intellectual projects
both scientific and theological we've
been examining here that is the new
naturalism as well as the new natural
theology notably here some of the same
psychological mechanisms that operate
among theists and theologians to avoid
cognitive dissonance as I described last
lecture and to protect their beliefs
from criticism operate among scientists
as well both individually and as members
of epistemic collectives indeed and more
generally precisely insofar as communal
norms are established and sustained
through what Macaulay calls the
institution of science the basic
theoretical assumptions and related
habits of perception shared among groups
of scientists get established and
sustained as well accordingly most
contemporary sociologists and
philosophers of science reject the old
logical empiricist positivist idea
always historically dubious
that Western science is automatically
and dependably self-correcting I
mentioned earlier that McCauley insists
on a quite narrow and arguably
tendentious definition of science to
appreciate its rarity he writes quoting
here Lewis Wolpert we must not confuse
it with technology Macaulay continues
quote the crucial point is that the
practical orientation of technology and
the abstract theoretical interest in
understanding nature that characterizes
science are not the same science is
finally concerned with understanding for
its own sake and not merely for its
effects upon us but the directive not to
confuse Science and Technology though
familiar is not so easy to satisfy on
the contrary distinguishing them at all
requires some significant retrospective
adjustments many of the specialized
pursuits we now associate with Western
science for example physics chemistry
anatomy and botany developed in close
conjunction with technical problem
solving in such ongoing human activities
as navigation agriculture medicine and
warfare a tradition and image of
gentleman investigators interested as
might be said in understanding the
workings of nature only for its own sake
emerged in the 17th century largely in
the science academies of England and
Europe but the conjunction with
practical activities continued and with
the dominance since world war two of
large-scale scientific ventures funded
mainly by government agencies and
corporations any effort to mark off a
realm of pure science pursued
independent of quote a practical
orientation toward technology can only
be arbitrary and artificial and
not saying it doesn't exist I'm saying
the effort to draw a clear line would be
very difficult the depictions of science
required to sustain the natural
unnatural contrast with religion are not
only historically strained but posed a
conceptual puzzle or new evolutionary
riddle for McCauley and the other new
naturalist's maintaining it for given
their identification of science with a
cognitively unnatural abstract
theoretical interest in understanding
nature for its own sake the question
arises as to how from an evolutionary
perspective it could have come into
existence and why it has survived among
humans at all not surprisingly
McCauley's arguments lead him to
represent science as he defines it as
something exceptionally fragile in
competition with religion as he defines
it he writes quote in the global
marketplace of ideas some views have
natural disadvantages science with its
esoteric interests it's counterintuitive
claims and its specialized forms of
thinking certainly seems to qualify some
scholars hold that science was one law
once lost one consequence of my view
this is Macaulay is that nothing about
human nature would ever prevent its loss
again end quote well this is very
ominous sounding but is there survival
of science non tendentious non
tendentious Lee defined really so
precarious and given the evolutionary
dynamics of human nature is represented
by the new naturalist's themselves are
the springs of science really all that
unnatural or indeed all that remote from
those of religion non tendentious Leda
find the evidence indicates that the
array of practices and techniques we now
call the Natural Sciences arose in the
course of our ancestors efforts to solve
practical problems such as
ival and were shaped overtime largely to
that end indeed rather than technology
being as McCauley would have it an
incidental byproduct of science it seems
that what he frames as the essence of
science quote the abstract theoretical
interest in understanding nature for its
own sake is an incidental offshoot of
technology that is a byproduct of
cognitive mechanisms naturally selected
for the accomplishment of practically
oriented activities McCauley's essential
science is thus would Boyer in accord
with the passage I quoted earlier would
call parasitic a form of behavior that
emerges and persists among humans not
because it confers fitness benefits
itself but because it as he says
recruits or piggybacks on cognitive and
other faculties that conferred such
benefits in the course of our evolution
pure science like other such behaviors
performing or listening to pure music
playing chess having sex for its own
sake and so forth exercises cognitive
faculties and satisfies bodily drives
that evolved in humans for particular
Fitness related functions but the
exercise or satisfaction of which is
also pleasurable in itself in the case
of science at least pure science this
would seem to be the pleasure of
constructing explanatory models of the
world just for the sake of making and
contemplating them quite apart from any
practical benefits they might leak yield
or as Macaulay puts it not merely for
their effects on us
interestingly a view of science as
parasitic in just this way has been
advanced by developmental cognitive
psychologists Alison Gopnik science is
successful she writes because it
capitalizes on a more basic human
capacity what she calls the theory
formation system drive according to
Gopnik citing experimental evidence the
fulfillment of that drive yields the
deep satisfaction that humans including
young children characteristically
experience in the production of a good
explanation she remarks quote science is
thus a kind of epi phenomenon of
cognitive development it is not only the
children are little scientists of you
that she advances elsewhere but that
scientists are big children and go
getting in effect a rush or high from
the fulfillment of an elementary drive
she compares it explicitly to sexual
pleasure much in Gopnik secound can be
disputed it's rather heavy for my taste
on dubiously postulated drives and
systems and the fulfillment high that
she claims is produced specifically by
the production of a good proto
scientific explanation is not clearly
distinguishable from the kinds of
satisfaction elicited by the successful
completion of any creative or
intellectual venture or indeed by the
successful execution of difficult
physical for example athletic feats but
her observations are suggestive and make
clear that what McCauley and others
alleged to be the cognitive
unnaturalness of science is by no means
self evident to all cognitive
researchers moreover and significantly
for another point I've been making here
and will continue to make got nicks
observations illustrate the possibility
of a thoroughly naturalistic
psychobiological account
of science itself and give some idea of
how disconcerting such an account not
debunking but still rather anti-heroic
might be the differences between science
and religion both duly historically
defined are profound and important and
the stakes both political and
intellectual and distinguishing them are
high but here as elsewhere I think the
better way to go both in the political
short run and the intellectual long run
is careful delineation and
discrimination rather than tendentious
characterization or exaggerated contrast
these are worried sometimes political
manipulation of public ignorance
threatens do communal regard for
scientific knowledge and indeed for the
pursuit of disciplined knowledge of any
kind free inquiry however and public
respect for intellectual ideals and
achievements are not served by sheer
scientific self celebration or by
strained efforts to demonstrate the
difference between science and
everything else which brings me to my
next topic here
aside from the political anxieties just
mentioned one reason for the polemical
temper of many new naturalist's that is
those practicing or promoting
evolutionary cognitive approaches to
religion is the common cognitive
tendency no doubt a survival of our
tribal past to identify strongly with
one or another community ethnic
professional religious and to experience
other communities especially those most
immediately adjacent or currently
visible contre distinctively in other
words to see the world in terms of us
versus them in the academic world the
tendency is reflected in various
disciplinary antagonisms for example
between clinical and experimental
psychologists or between cultural and
physical anthropologists and in the
broader to culture ideology that
continues to dominate the contemporary
Academy that is the conviction among
many scientists and humanists not merely
of important and arguably valuable
differences between their respective
pursuits but of their fundamental
antagonism as I've detailed elsewhere
that ideology with its intellectual
provincial isms and self promoting other
demoting stereotypes is especially
egregious these days in the field of
evolutionary psychology and among its
promoters and practitioners including a
number of new naturalist's people I've
discussed the stereotypes here include a
constellation of routinely disparaged
and commonly conflated others
theologians scholars of religious
studies cultural anthropologists and
most other social sciences tists
academics working in the humanities and
to be sure post modernists
the sorts of intellectual mischief
involved are illustrated in Daniel
Dennett's new book breaking the spell
religion as a natural phenomenon dennett
celebrates the evolutionary psych
cognitive accounts of religion that
we've been reviewing here he cites Boyer
at rijn and McCauley and berkett the
last rather patronizingly the humanist
in the bunch he celebrates them against
what he represents as a history of
academic resistance and indeed
prohibition Dennett writes quote this is
a long quote and I'm going to be going
over various of its turns of phrase
dennett writes the ardent anti Darwinian
in the humanities and Social Sciences
have traditionally feared that an
evolutionary approach would drown their
cherished ways of thinking with its
heroic authors and arts and inventors
and other defenders and lovers of ideas
and so they have tended to declare with
desperate conviction but no evidence or
argument that human culture and human
society can only be interpreted and
never causally explained using methods
and presuppositions that are completely
in commencement ooh the methods and
presuppositions of the Natural Sciences
and group the mischief here is
substantial then it supplies no names
citations or direct quotations but what
he represents as the desperate
convictions and traditional fears of
ardent anti Darwinian in the humanities
and Social Sciences a certainly not
characteristic of either the views or
the motives of those who maintain the
value of interpretive approaches as
distinct from the search for explanatory
theories in their particular fields
there are significant issues of method
in regard to the study of human social
and
cultural phenomena and as I've indicated
at various points in these lectures the
array of positions on those issues is
complex not a matter as then it suggests
here of enlightened evolutionary
theorists on the one side and hysterical
boobies on the other something like the
exclusivist position dennett portrays
here only interpretation never
explanation has been maintained in
religious studies by scholars like
Mircea Eliade ah who was I noted in the
first lecture invoked what they see is
the unique and in effect hallowed
character of religion to argue against
the very possibility of a naturalistic
approach to the subject insofar as this
position has dominated the field of
religious studies it has certainly
confined its disciplinary horizons but
these limiting positions in religious
studies and related self stultifying
attitudes among humanities teachers and
students and teachers are very different
from the views and motives with which
then it conflates them here the latter
include first the reasonable observation
among scholars in the field of religious
studies quite independent and often in
defiance of theological apologetics that
an adequate understanding of the
religions of the world individually and
generally requires among other things
the sorts of historical comparative and
interpretive approaches associated with
the humanities as distinct from the
experimental explanatory approaches
associated with the Natural Sciences
comparable positions that is views to
the effect that interpretive and other
non Natural Science non explanatory
approaches are crucial to the
intellectual aims of a particular field
of study can be found among art
historians literary scholars
musicologists philosophers
various social scientists as well many
anthropologists for example maintain the
value of emic approaches that is insider
participant viewpoint to the study such
approaches to the study of other
cultures as distinct from eating
outsider observer viewpoint approaches
though again not characteristically to
the exclusion of the latter more
generally scholars in most humanities
fields are persuaded that there's a
distinctive intellectual value to
historical critical and interpretive
approaches to such specifically human
activities and productions as art music
literature and philosophy the view
dennett evidently derives here as quote
their cherished way of thinking with its
heroic authors and arts and inventors
and other defenders and lovers of ideas
and quote for scholars maintaining such
a view that is of the distinctive value
of interpretive and historical
approaches and I count myself among them
the value of such approaches is indeed
incommensurable with natural science
explanations not in the sense that they
are immeasurably superior to explanatory
approaches which i think is what Dennett
is implying but in the sense that their
intellectual products descriptions
exegesis historical placements
comparisons and so forth cannot be
assessed by the same measures used to
assess scientific explanations in
commencer evil finally in this
connection many academics including I
believe many scientists would agree that
the characteristic methods and products
of the humanities disciplines
interpretations historical placements
and so forth are as den it puts it in
tones of I think maize mint quote
untranslatable into the methods and
presuppositions of the Natural Science
is end quote but they would find it hard
to see why he finds the idea so
stupefying all the positions i just
described argue for the distinctive
irreplaceable value of descriptive
interpretive historical or critical
approaches in fields that have as their
aim forms of understanding insight
connection making and reflection that
are not characteristically sought in the
Natural Sciences and not
characteristically produced by causal
explanations derived from natural
science models none of these positions
that I've described however issues from
quote a traditional fear of evolutionary
approaches and the totality of those
positions does not amount to what
Dennett refers to as a taboo on the
pursuit of naturalistic explanations of
human and cultural phenomena musicology
maintains no taboo against psycho
acoustic explanations of musical sound
literary studies maintains no taboo
against empirical studies of book
production or psychological explanations
of literary and aesthetic reception
these and comparable naturalistic
approaches in art history classical
studies and other humanistic disciplines
have long been staple methods in the
fields in question and with regard to
religious phenomena in particular the
dominance of interpretive and so-called
phenomenological approaches in the field
of religious studies as such has not
presented two centuries worth of
empirical study and naturalistic
explanation of religious beliefs
behaviors and institutions by
anthropologists archaeologists
historians psychologists and
sociologists this amounts to thousands
and thousands of titles most of them
informed by evolutionary
this from the beginning and none of them
involved in the rejection of Darwinian
or evolutionary theory as such so what
taboo exactly is Dennett talking about
and who exactly are the ardent anti
Darwinian whose views so exercise him
here the answer I think is that there is
no effective taboo at all there are
certain people who would like to see
naturalistic explanations go away and
who keep them to a minimum in their
field but there's no effective taboo at
all and I also think that the people at
issue whose views exercise Dennett and
whom he calls ardent anti Darwinian a
phrase that evokes creationists or
religious fundamentalists holding forth
in university classrooms not so much
these as academics largely in the
humanities and Social Sciences who have
challenged the intellectual aims and
claims of certain evolutionary
approaches in particular and who have
noted the intellectual limits and
methodological problems of the
particular explanations of human or
cultural phenomena offered in the name
of such approaches in their own fields
and elsewhere these suspicions are
deepened by the close resemblance of
Dennett's distorted representation here
of humanities scholars to their equally
distorted representation in recent works
by EO wilson and Steven Pinker and by
their followers in various fields
including the humanities to be sure
there are ideologues on both sides of
the two culture divide and
indiscriminate hostility to science and
ignorant rejection of biology by some
students and teachers and Humanities
exists for institutional reasons I would
be glad to discuss later but these are
very different from scholars in the
humanities literary studies history
classics philosophy who resists the
uncritical
and barely digested importation of terms
and methods from one or another
currently highly visible scientific
field such as currently evolutionary
psychology what is characteristically
resisted in these latter instances
however is not empirical study as such
or the possibility of naturalistic or
biological or indeed evolutionary
explanations as such but the claim of
scientific Authority for crude glib
pedestrian and otherwise dubious
intellectual where then it represents
the promotion of interpretive methods in
the study of religion as a self-deluding
spell designed by religious believers in
the Academy to protect their personal
beliefs from demystification accordingly
he represents the emergence of the new
naturalism that is naturalistic
explanations of religion by way of
evolutionary theory and cognitive
science as the breaking of a spell by a
few brave iconoclasts or I suppose
Prince Charming's and the triumph
through their efforts of reason and
science over fear and superstition at
the same time like Lewis Wolpert EO
wilson and steven pinker Dennett brushes
aside as an aberration of post-modernism
the project of contemporary science
studies which is to say the breaking of
a quite explicit and effective taboo in
fields such as sociology and philosophy
against the naturalistic study of
science I noted the irony of this
conjunction at the end of the last
lecture in institutional intellectual
terms it amounts to a science
exceptionalism that makes everything
subject to naturalistic explanation
except science itself in personal
intellectual terms among the scientists
involved it amounts to a seriously
debilitating myopia and self ignorance
Nietzsche wrote in 1887 that Natural
Science in its aesthetic self-discipline
and steadfast faith in truth was the
latest and perhaps the last expression
of priestly religious ideals he also
wrote in a comment especially apt here
quote unnatural science is the self
critique of knowledge end quote
self-critique self-questioning has long
been seen as crucial crucial to the
practices of science and indeed as in
Dennett's book as distinguishing
scientific knowledge from the dogmen
dogmatism associated with religious
doctrine but what nietzsche is
suggesting here is that the science that
would be truly unnatural in the sense of
extraordinary would be that which
questioned not merely individual
hypotheses but its own most fundamental
assumptions about the very nature of
scientific knowledge it was of course
just such a self-critique as pursued
throughout the 20th century by various
historians philosophers and sociologists
of science that issued in the project we
now call science studies not
irrelevantly it also issued in a
widespread rejection of the rationalist
epistemology and derived scientistic
views of science that sustained dubious
understandings such as Dennett's and
McCauley's of the relation between
science and religion which brings me to
my final comments here
I've observed throughout these lectures
that scientists studying religion are
subject to the same general cognitive
dispositions that they identify as
natural to the human species and that
they see is responsible for some of the
central features of religion of course
that doesn't make science just another
belief like shamanism or presbyterianism
though I would have to add that none of
these in my view is just a belief either
the systems of norms and practices that
define Western science notably
naturalism empiricism and experimentals
constitute and extremely efficient
apparatus for generating models of the
operations of the phenomenal physical
universe that permit us to predict
control and intervene in those
operations with maximum reliability to
the extent that shame anism or
presbyterianism seek such ends that is
reliable prediction control and
intervention Western science is better
at achieving them all so many definitive
norms and characteristic practices of
science such as the exclusion of
religious ideas the open publication of
procedures and the honoring of
theoretical innovation are especially
effective ways to limit the liabilities
of our humanly shared cognitive
dispositions but the effectiveness of
scientific norms and practices in both
these respects that is practical
reliability and cognitive discipline
does not make science the only kind of
human knowledge there is or the only
kind worth seeking in noting the
naturalness and all two humanists of
science my aim here as i think is clear
has not been to secure a place in the
academy for religious profession if
there's a place I'm especially concerned
to see secured is for the sort of
cognate
have activities exploratory interpretive
critical and reflective commonly seen as
central to the humanities though they
have often been pursued as part of the
natural and social sciences as well
while the general pursuit of such
activities is probably irrepressible
among humans they're disciplined pursuit
seems to be at risk in an increasingly
productive 'used and sometimes
unabashedly bottom line Academy most
scientists along with most other
academics recognize the existence of
more subtle goods for themselves
individually and more long-range goods
for the community at large I speak of
such things as open-ended intellectual
exploration civilized reflection the
enjoyment of art and the mastery of
fields of not especially marketable
knowledge but concern for such goods is
generally left to the humanities as is
also responsibility for the transmission
of the skills archival textual aesthetic
and so forth that enable participation
in them since the continued display of
that concern and performance of those
tasks benefit the entire academic and
intellectual community and beyond it
would make sense i think for scientists
and their spokesmen to join with others
who seek to preserve a place for them in
the contemporary university this would
mean at the least rejecting Natural
Science imperialism and to culture
caricatures of the humanities wherever
they occur it would also mean
acknowledging the academic and broader
intellectual value of not immediately
applicable or marketable cognitive
activities exploration interpretation
criticism and reflection wherever they
occur this brings us close to full
circle today scientists share cognitive
tendency
and limits with non-scientists non
religionists share them with
religionists although each may put the
world together and conduct his or her
life in ways that are at odds with or
opaque to the other the ontology and way
of life of each deserves minimally
respectful acknowledgment from the other
such acknowledgement would not mean
accepting ideas one finds fantastic or
claims one knows are false and of course
it would not mean approving practices
one knows are confining maiming or
murderous to oneself or others what it
would mean is recognizing as parallel to
one's own the all-too-human processes by
which they came to be formed not me says
the self haunting evangelical skeptic to
quote way you too says the defensive
resentful theists at Eagle Eye to says
the reflexive reflective naturalist
well thank you for going through all
that and making it accessible but I
wouldn't as a scientist but my champions
flow it as evolutionary psychologists or
as cognitive psychologist but
unfortunately they are the ones who have
would enter into this debate that you
are facing and I think that science
although you treated it carefully and
treated in exactly the way I would
endorse it be enthusiastic if more
people did but science itself has more
heft and more reliability than the likes
of those who are formulating criticisms
of everything from the viewpoint of
evolutionary psychology which is built
upon very shaky legs so I just wanted to
say that and you forced into that
position and you've exploded brilliantly
and I've enjoyed every minute of it but
these are not my champions my life I
know that done believe it I sometimes
refer to scientific and what I call
cyan't I'd projects so but I don't want
to overload my descriptions with let's
say suggestion of undercut them even as
I'm doing them so yes certainly they
claim science and much that is done in
the name of evolutionary psychology is
science and much that is done in the
name of evolutionary psychology as I
said in the first lecture is at some
distance from science well the question
would be whether the terms of this
debate don't bring out don't select a
particular section of science which you
know it may not reflect
I mean the debate between religion and
science that that made that's that's a
good point thanks Barbara I know we've
talked about this before you and I and
it was raising when the discussions by
one of our graduate students earlier
this week I I want to hear you say a bit
more whenever I get in these kind of
conversations as a person in religious
studies I tend to spend a lot of time
trying to educate people who aren't so
familiar with what's going on religious
studies now that one of the things that
we are doing and have been doing as you
know the last of years is saying you
know this whole thing that there is
something called religion that is that
everybody knows when they see it is very
problematic and usually what that gets
boiled down to is something that could
be no more substantial than human beings
making meaning out of the world their
experience are trying to come up with
some ultimate meaning and if that's all
we mean by religion which is not what
most people out the street mean by
religion and it's a problematic category
for comparison purposes because you
might find that everywhere but so what
if you found the other thing is that we
keep reminding people that when we in
the Academy have done have studied
things that we are willing to designate
as religious phenomena or religions we
actually have started off with a modern
in the Protestant notion of what
Christianity is of the combination of
doctrine ethics and ritual for example
that any religion will have those three
things and of course we probably
realized well that's very problematic
and we've so we've criticized these
things all along and it gets to the
point where you kind of think well when
these when other people are talking
about religion as this universal human
phenomenon what exactly are they talking
about I have to admit that as a
non-scientist when they talk about the
scientific
method I don't from the outside I can't
see that there is one it looks like me a
lots of different methods so I'm kind of
getting probably with just these two
terms as so universalizing and I know
you've thought about this you've talked
about more though from the point of view
looking at science than looking at
religion so far the lectures well thanks
very much Dale all of those observations
are well taken I do touch on a number of
them at various points in the lectures
specifically with regard to religion of
course in today's lecture I objected to
treating both of them as monolithic and
on historically in the first lecture I
did point out that they're the sort of
crisis for Religious Studies comparable
with the term the heterogeneity and the
historical limitations and the notions
of ethnocentrism I didn't know about
Protestant centrism but I take your word
for it of the very a category of
religion as being a problem for
religious studies comparable to the
problem very very similar of what we
mean by culture in anthropology and what
we mean by literature in literary
studies and what we mean by art in art
history all of these terms once one
starts being reflexive and reflective
about them are open to very similar
forms of commentary that is that they
are reification that they are terms that
have their limits defined very often by
the very disciplines that take them as
objects of study and that their
definition as domains of phenomena
become very very difficult to establish
otherwise I also did say at the at a
certain point in the second lecture and
you might have been referring to this
that when you begin to follow the new
naturalist definitions of religion
indeed it does seem to be something that
is
everywhere your own comment was that
that made it nothing I'm not sure that
that makes it nothing that is it may be
interesting then to pursue what it is
that is characterized as religion by
noticing the ways in which those
features are exhibited in that which we
don't otherwise named religious so that
those are them the ways in which i would
comment respond to that yes hello i want
to comment about science and the
tendency to think that science consists
of the theoreticians and then there's
technology which is not science but
there is also experimental science these
people have the job of falsification
that's unique in physics there's
probably much more money goes into that
then into theoretical work and it's it's
a very important distinction technology
comes out mostly out of their work but
their science and that's a unique an
important thing I was once taught the
scientific method and learned that it
doesn't exist thank you yes I quite
agree with that i think i would add and
you probably won't disagree that the
distinction between the theoretical the
experimental and the applied okay is
itself difficult to maintain even not
only within a discipline but even within
a particular scientists work in other
words these these are in continuous one
is part what one is doing as a scientist
is theorizing experimenting conceiving
of how
things when one says application how
they might turn out what might be made
of them well the distinction has a great
deal well that what I'm not to load the
word too much but these are also
ideological distinctions and they also
come attached with their own stereotypes
of the theoretical as opposed to the
applied scientist of the
experimentalists the bench scientist as
opposed to someone who does innovative
theorizing it was you know that these
distinctions are also made up by
scientists yes do you talk about new
naturalism and not told us so much about
whether there was an old naturalism but
it would seem to me that this is really
not a new subject that this goes back to
the Hippocratic writing about the sacred
disease and Hildegard of Bingen visions
explained by her migraine headaches and
so on and and they ended to satisfy
professor Schulman using the the gold
standard of science that is MRI imaging
the studies of monks meditating in the
MRI machine and so on I mean neuro
theology which is a new camp subject
yeah so obviously this is just the
Darwinian context of this long tradition
I have given the name the new naturalism
as literally just a shorthand otherwise
I could say mmm those approaches that
call themselves caught into the
evolutionary particularly as published
within the past 15 years and with the
following people as the major figures so
the new naturalism has been for purposes
here shorthand reference but I did say
at the very beginning that naturalism
indeed I opposed Pascal boyars claim
here we offer the first time giving
naturalistic explanations of religion
and I did
race considerable objection to that and
rolled out a list of names beginning
with Lucretia sand quotations from Hume
and so forth hi this is sort of based on
the questions that I've been that came
up afterwards and just sort of curious
whether it makes a difference if we talk
about scientific knowledge versus faith
rather than science versus religion and
whether that affects how we talk about
these entities so I think for many kinds
of contrasts it does make a difference
when whether one is opposing let's a
scientific doctrine or two religious
doctrine or if one thinks about science
is a body of knowledge and religion as a
body of doctrine as opposed to thinking
of them as institutions sets of
practices sets of norms or whatever
because it's so variable yes certainly
yes
if I understood the observation
correctly it's just that different kinds
of comparisons contrasts and connections
are made if you are thinking of science
primarily as a set of ongoing practices
and institutions and opposing it to
religion as a set of ongoing practices
and institutions or if you are opposing
religious doctrine and dogma to
scientific knowledge I'm just saying
that you would have different ways of
drawing the distinction that's all I
think that was the point yes I mean
science and religion have both have
those cultural features as institutions
but i think it's different yeah as an
essential way knowing and I'm not even
talking about sighs but I said I'd said
that at great length I said that the
scientific norms practices that we
identify with Western science r is an
apparatus that is especially effective
may be maximally effective in developing
if I'm quoting myself but models of the
operations of the physical phenomenal
world that enable their prediction
control and intervention so that I think
distinguishes what it is that science
achieves and what it is that science
aims at from I said shame anism or
presbyterianism if that's what they're
aiming for certainly science does that
better that's I said that struck out by
a concluding statement about the common
ground between scientists and
non-scientists as the cognitive limits
and once again Alma Terry the late again
oh the common ground between sciences
non-scientists the cognitive limits
share by both and cognitive limits
likewise as the common ground between
people who are religious and people who
are not so it seems to me a very
interesting way to think about where
people can come together actually it's
not in what they believe in or what they
profess but in a some kind of limited
which I can't yeah you know thank you
yes certainly yes would you want to give
your eye I'm very happy to see you again
but you should give you a name and your
way of coming from for for my name is
Louie Dupree and my profession is
philosophy or at least teaching it I
would like to ask two more questions the
first one is this what you think of the
following proposition given and granted
that the evolutionary science too
limited to that particular science has
nothing to say about theology about at
the physics and so on which we would
take for granted now as long as they do
not exclude any kind of metaphysical or
philosophical or anthropological speech
that deals with that no I should exclude
that were down topological that's wrong
but any kind of approach that deals with
definite transcendence desert might
fading nonsense yesterday I am trying to
avoid the word God here but for a moment
given that could we not say the
following that intelligent design must
be out of biology yes because at that
point we the person who advocates that
interferes with one of the most critical
points in the evolution
science at least in the mutation theory
namely the fortuitous character of the
mutations the contingent character
limitations on the other hand the
biologist must be left with the question
which you formulated in the beginning
that why is the nature of this guy I
never asked that quote a skittish was
posed and I quoted it last time from
heart namely yes science doesn't ask the
why question I think science I agree
lions asks lots of wine OS I mean as a
human being there scientists will we
wondered why is there why is it that we
can work this way where there are people
who don't for whom that question does
not arise as a question it doesn't in
other words the naturally occurring
world is simply taken as naturally
occurring the question of why suggest a
certain way of interpreting up being
obliged to or interpreting namely that
there is going to be an answer to a wine
nearly whatever I don't that I don't
think that the why question is built
into anything I think it occurs over and
over again but I think that it comes
from a way that is already in place of
thinking in other words it comes from
the existence of purposive scripts that
one says but why if one doesn't have
teleological scenarios that one is
operating with one need not ask the like
what's going to freeze them if you if
you don't matter except that let's
rephrase it this way that it is not
excluded as a human being why would I
have divided I have said it's not
excluded what can prevent a human being
from asking my quest
question is by no means a critique of
your talk no I understand it's trying to
confirm but understand the following
question that there if that if that
issue can be raised then it seems to me
that we go in religion with a very
difficult problem here how can we race
in religion the question of God or the
question of transcendence after we have
somehow in evolution and particularly in
the intervention and in the whole
question of creation after we have more
or less eliminated that from that field
and have particularly excluded the
notion of intelligent design so I I
excluded that I do have a problem I mean
I can believe in God I can accept on
sentence but when it comes to saying
what is creation then what is it if we
eliminate that from there then we
witness to come in religion not in
biology but inter listened with some
kind of so I put that formulation where
we would have to say yes there is a
question here for us religious people
that's the first thing the second
question is the following I think if the
people in religion are getting a lot of
flak from characters like darkens and
delicate it's a little bit also their
own fault if I may say so fanatical as
the talk is there is not only a
biological naturalism with the results
are at theological naturalism for
example this thing started I think
really becoming a problem in their 16th
century
ooh and early seventeen because at that
point we started raising questions in
terms of physics for example the whole
the whole Cartesian and spillage istic
questions are formed about God are
formulated entirely in terms derived
from the phone mechanistic physics you
know what is the mechanistic cause of
the world they've caused a motion mm-hmm
and I also think that this has not been
proved quite the opposite in other words
it's the naturalistic pretensions of
religion that you find exposes it to the
kind of reaction that you get in Dawkins
indented I listen today you have to say
in religious studies to someone you're
here nothing but words like models and
paradigms and all that stuff that is
straight they can alter the book of so
on these toothbrushes f I would like to
have enough well i think i actually have
have answered in other words i think
that the notion of what comes out what
inevitably comes out of religion and out
of a religious sensibility you have
described well and i don't think we
disagree i hope not that it's possible
not to have a religious sensibility and
it's possible not to be in religion but
to be someplace else the second point i
just i simply think it's a very nice
point i don't myself know that much
contemporary theological writing but I
take your word for it it sounds very
very plausible that it has its own forms
of scientism that expose it to claims
that it wants to frame claims that
theologians want to frame in scientific
terms and therefore exposes them to the
kind of response that one gets from
Dawkins again
that seems fine to make up a proper
observation yes no my neck my name is
Willard Mariah the computer science
department I think I heard you say many
of your talk about science itself was
was filled or replete with metaphysics I
know I didn't that's what I said is that
there are places in at the limits of
scientific knowledge where the
assumptions can only be called
metaphysical because at those limits the
empirical appeal is faltering simply
because it is well I want to applaud you
for saying that I see and I want to say
that you probably should have run more
with that idea and including the
criticism that scientists take
themselves far too seriously perhaps at
that point we should call mobile cities
to a conclusion and acts their fastest
path for witnesses
lectures
you